[Música]
el momento no es casual en medio de las
conmemoraciones de la revolución de 1911
el presidente xi jinping volvió a hablar
sobre el destino de taiwán en el palacio
del pueblo de beijing ante una sala
llena aseguró que la reunificación con
el pequeño estado insular es inevitable
y la separación de taiwán es el mayor
obstáculo para la reunificación de la
madre patria también representa un
peligro oculto para la renovación de
nuestra nación
el presidente sí jinping habló de
reunificación pacífica pero sobre el
terreno es mucho más agresivo desde el
pasado viernes unos 150 bienes militares
chinos han estado incursionando en la
zona de defensa aérea de taiwán que
china siempre ha considerado como su
provincia rebelde la presión militar
pero también diplomática y económica han
aumentado desde 2016 y la llegada al
poder en taiwán de chagin wayne la
presidenta de un partido independentista
es la oveja negra de los comunistas
da igual no busca la confrontación
militar queremos una coexistencia
pacífica estable predecible y mutuamente
beneficiosa con nuestros vecinos pero
taiwán hará todo lo posible para
defender su libertad y su modo de vida
democrático
taiwán espera contar con el apoyo de
washington la administración baiden ha
afirmado que se opondrá a cualquier
acción unilateral de beijing estamos muy
preocupados por las actividades
militares provocativas de china acerca
de taiwán un ansia de liniers agua
crisis esto sería un error de cálculo ya
que podría socavar la paz y la
estabilidad de la región y sustituir el
jueves funcionarios del pentágono
confirmaron que las fuerzas especiales
estadounidenses llevan varios meses
entrenando a soldados taiwaneses china
por su parte siempre ha advertido contra
cualquier injerencia extranjera en el
conflicto